et cette conférence de presse on en
parle ce soir avec nos invités à
pierre-yves rouleront la président du
cercle de réflexion aristote et notre
éditorialiste alexis poulain
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir pour débriefer est ce ce
discours cette conférence de presse des
manuels macron un discours assez long un
très garni avec six poulains je me
tourne vers vous d'abord qu'elle est
tout simplement votre analyse après
cette conférence de presse du chef de
l'état je crois que c'était un discours
extrêmement long qui était d'abord fait
pour les partenaires européens et en
particulier pour le nouveau chancelier
allemand expliquant que cette présidence
française ne serait pas celle de la
campagne du candidat emmanuel macron
même si ce sera le cas mais rassurant
les partenaires européens en disant
qu'il y aurait un plan sur la table et
il parlait davantage aux autres pays
européens conférence est d'où la
longueur de cette conférence de presse
d'où les thèmes aussi abordé qui sauf
pour certains des serpents de mer pour
d'autres des thèmes d'actualité brûlante
sur schengen sur l'immigration bien sûr
mais la question bien sûr de la
souveraineté européenne
ça reste un voeu pieux ça me paraît
difficile à faire en l'état actuel des
traités donc c'était pour moi une
feuille de route qui avait pour but de
rassurer les pays membres de l'union
européenne plus que les français qu'ils
comprennent bien que cette présidence va
servir le président sortant dans sa
campagne dans sa déclaration de
candidature et puis arrive aux gens pour
le disais à l'instant lexip poulain le
disais à l'instant l'un des thèmes
majeurs qui a été abordé pendant cette
conférence de presse c'est la
souveraineté européenne
est ce que la souveraineté européenne
est possible sachant que on le rappelle
dans l'union européenne est composée
quand même de 27 pays
de l'union européenne a été créée pour
déposséder la souveraineté aux
populations et aux états qui la
composent fou quand même revenir là
dessus et ce n'est pas un accident de
l'histoire toute personne qui a lu les
mémoires de jean monnet c'est ce que ce
qu'on appelle les pères fondateurs
art d'ailleurs par rapport à une nation
de monde européennes qui étaient les
pères fondateurs dette unis pensent et
de la souveraineté donc il y aura il ne
peut pas y avoir pour de souveraineté
européenne
premièrement ce que la souveraineté
c'est déjà un fait matériel
quelqu'un qui par exemple ne veux pas
avoir d'armé et beaucoup de pays
européens ne veulent pas en avoir ne
sera jamais souverain il renonce à
l'histoire pour vivre dans une sorte de
grande suisse attention je ne critique
pas je fais un constat la france elle a
encore des velléités d'exister dans
l'histoire ses partenaires n'en n'ont
pas alors est-ce que c'est nous qui
allons plier eux vous voyez tout de
suite vous voyez qu'il n'y a pas
d'intérêt il n'y a pas de vision commune
ya rien souveraineté européenne ça sert
à un truc ça sert à capter le mot
souveraineté parce que celui-ci plaît
aux populations pour une raison c'est
qu'ils veulent avoir une autonomie dans
l'histoire ils veulent redevenir des
sujets et arrêter d'être des objets et
donc vous vous détruisez la chose on en
subtilisant le nom c'est une technique
tout à fait connu de des rhéteurs et des
sophistes emmanuel macron de n'en est
qu'un parmi d'autres en vingt-cinq
siècles d'histoire occidental alexis
poulain accordé à 27 pays tentez de de
parler d'une seule et même voix est ce
que est ce que c'est possible
non bien sûr c'est impossible prenez un
cale dans l'actualité le boycott des
jeux olympiques à pékin en chine on voit
clairement un accent anglo-saxon qui
s'est dessinée la france a dit de son
côté non nous ne boycottons pas parce
que nous n'aurons pas les moyens une
pâle envie non plus je suis sûr que
certains pays européens qui sont de
l'otan qui sont alignés par rapport aux
états unis ne seront jamais d'accord
avec la france même s'ils n'annonceront
pas forcément un boycott des jo pareil
pour les intérêts que ce soit en afrique
ou les intérêts sur les territoires
d'outre-mer on a là à faire regarder
l'épisode des sous marins
là encore une fois la france s'est fait
flouer par des partenaires qui se posent
en grands frères en amis mais qui sont
des compétiteurs qui sonde
alors un petit sous gestion qui un petit
souci de sont effectivement dus côtés
d'alexis
t2 on va tenter de résoudre ça tout de
suite c'est pour ça que je me tourne
vers vous un pierre yves rochon je vous
pose la même question accordé 27 27 pays
pour parler d'une seule et même voix sur
sur la scène internationale est ce que
est ce que c'est possible et surtout
dans les six prochains mois de mai
premièrement c'est un faisable on soit
c'est un faisable on délais et surtout
est-ce que ce serait
profitable pour les intérêts des peuples
concernés alors déjà d'une autre excusez
moi moi je parle pour les miens je
prends pas le place des autres
je vais vous donner un exemple on aurait
fait la grande union européenne avec les
gens qui étaient d'accord à
l'international eh bien la france aurait
participé au crime contre l'humanité qui
a été la guerre d'irak de 2003 voilà
voilà là vous auriez pu avoir une
unanimité il ya eu quasiment que la
france contre et berlin qui a fait
semblant 2 avant d'aller payer pour
redevenir l'allier préféré de washington
donc prenez l'exemple sur la russie si
la france et on va être d'accord il ya
un processus pour que tout le monde soit
d'accord c'est donc un processus à la
majorité des états on est d'accord bon
c'est à dire que les minoritaires pli si
c'est le cas alors il y aura une
escalade avec moscou et peut-être même
une escalade militaire mauges étaient
cinq ans au parlement européen j'ai
entendu des discours délirant venant des
diplomaties d'europe de l'est de
certains diplomates allemands
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs en poste
qui alors heureusement ce sont des
discours de nuque ce sont des gens qui
n'ont pas les moyens de leur violence
mais imaginez que la france soit
contrainte d'avoir des positions aussi
délirante face à la chine ou face à la
russie et nous vivrons dans un monde
beaucoup plus dangereux est en tout cas
où les intérêts français seront piétinés
parce que jusqu'à preuve du contraire
l'intérêt de la france et d'avoir des
rapports
profitable avec moscou et profitable
avec pékin alors on va évoquer dans un
instant dos ils craignent un avec vous
messieurs mais juste avant j'aurais aimé
revenir
sur deux principaux points évoqués
également par emmanuel macron lors de
cette conférence de presse le premier il
appelle l'europe à réformer l'espace
schengen
qui fait un partie des priorités du chef
de l'état est à revoir les frontières
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
dites alexis poulain est ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est ces sujets sont
prioritaires alors ils sont prioritaires
mais là encore le choix de le faire par
la concertation politique dire qu'il
faut un règlement politique de l'espace
schengen c'est simplement continuer
exactement la même chose dépossédé les
pays de leurs frontières on voit bien
qu'il ya deux problèmes à la fois
schengen qui la libre circulation et on
l'a vu depuis les attaques terroristes
c'est un vrai problème de sécurité
publique et le deuxième problème c'est
là aussi la coopération
le fait de dire qu'il ya des pays
frontières qui n'ont pas du tout la même
vision de l'immigration que des pays qui
sont protégés par des pays tampon c'est
le cas de la hongrie de la pologne de la
grèce de l'italie de la france dans une
certaine mesure à calais et là on voit
bien que c'est pas du tout la même façon
d'appréhender le phénomène migratoire or
qu'est ce que dit emmanuel macron bien
qu'il va organiser une coopération
européenne elle n'a jamais eu lieu ça
fait 20 ans que la crise migratoire
existe elle a eu des pics terrible lors
de la guerre en syrie personne ne s'est
mis d'accord autour de la table jean
claude juncker parler de quotas les
quotas n'ont pas vu le jour chaque pays
essaye de dire qu'ils aident mais en
fait n'être pas donc qu'est-ce qu'on a
là on a du verbiage on a du blabla on a
une mise en scène de la capacité
européenne de sécuriser ses frontières
et d'assurer aux pays membres le eux
mêmes la sécurisation de leurs propres
frontières si on veut être sérieux avec
schengen c'est simple il faut rétablir
les frontières intra européennes
or on ne peut pas le faire ça irait à
l'encontre du libre marché de la libre
circulation des biens et des services du
marché unique or ce marché unique il
marche pour les marchandises
on le voit même avec le brick city où il
ya eu des détournements de traiter pour
s'assurer de la circulation pour les
personnes c'est plus compliqué alors on
met un pass sanitaires c'est une façon
de refermer les frontières d'une
certaine façon sur une base sanitaire
d'habituer les européens un passeport
intra européen il est pour le moment
vaccinale mais demain c'est l'art le
retour tout simplement des frontières
sans le dire parce que ça veut dire la
fin finalement de ce projet européen
libéral de libre-marché d'inspiration
atlantiste on voit bien la limite la
limite est atteinte aujourd'hui à la
fois dans l'inflation l'euro qui n'est
pas une monnaie qui va forcément
protéger parce qu'il ya trop de
disparités et puis les frontières les
frontières ça va devenir un problème
cuisant puisque ce phénomène migratoire
ne fait que commencer et puis arrive un
rouge dont je vous voyais pendant
l'analyse d'alexis poulain vous semblez
plutôt d'accord sur cette question en
tous cas la pierre et de la réforme de
l'espace schengen alors si vous voulez
la réforme de l'espace schengen ça sert
à tout ça sert à deux choses ça sert à
faire passer la pilule
de la normalisation des pays qui n'ont
pas été récalcitrants qui étaient juste
des pays que je qualifierais de sales
gosses en échange de subsides qui était
la hongrie la pologne ces pays là vont
être calmé par une attaque sur les fonds
sur les fonds structurels
ce qui au passage je veux dire
l'écrasement de la démocratie polonaise
et hongroise
alors c'est pas l'écrasement de budapest
d'accord mais ça veut dire voilà vous
êtes mis sous tutelle par la commission
dont très bien donc pour pouvoir calmer
faire passer la pilule on va parler de
l'europe qui protège zae l'europe qui
protège c'est pour draguer les vieux les
boumeurs de droite comme l'europe
sociale c'était pour draguer les
boumeurs de gauche vous savez c'est un
artifice totalement totalement éculés
c'est pour faire calmer les opinions qui
commencent à comprendre que le lieu ne
leur veut pas bien en plus je vous
rappelle qu'il faut bien parler aux gens
des deux temps en tant de choses qui les
concernent comme l'immigration ou autre
quand on est une union européenne
qui vient d'avoir des scandales
financiers majeurs qu'elle arrive pour
l'instant à maintenir sous le boisseau
par la collaboration active des prez
occidentale et deuxièmement qui fait des
couacs de communication
extraordinaire rappelez vous il y à un
mois cette affaire sur le hidjab de
toute beauté donc le il n'y a pas le
choix il faut enrhumé une partie des
électeurs dans une approche électorale
particulièrement quand vous et emmanuel
macron et que votre ennemi actuelle
c'est la candidat de centre-droit qui se
disputent le même électorat que vous qui
est le seul europe électorat en france
qui reste europhile
messieurs juste avant de vous quitter
j'aurais aimé parler d'un dossier très
brièvement puisqu'on a plus beaucoup le
tant le dossier ukrainien d'en parler
tout à l'heure emmanuel macron a dit
quelques mots à ce sujet alors de cette
conférence de presse vers le site et il
appelle à continuer à engager un
dialogue exigeant avec avec la russie
sur le dossier ukrainien
alexis poulain d'abord très brièvement
est ce que le dialogue exigeant est une
bonne stratégie pour la pour la france
envers la russie
alors pour la france oui enfin de
dialoguer vision ça dépend ce qu'on veut
dire mais regardez sur le dossier
ukrainien s'est d'abord les présidents
baden et poutine qui se parlent
directement je ne vois pas ni l'un ni
l'autre prendre un téléphone et appeler
madame von der leyen pour avoir l'avis
de la commission européenne ou appelés
un par un les chefs d'état européens sur
quelle est leur position par rapport à
ça l'europe reste un nain diplomatique
malgré les annonces et les plans fumeux
de défense européenne et pour ce qui est
de la position française elle est une
position particulière du moins elle
l'était jusqu'au quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy à savoir le non alignement on se
rappelait de l'intervention en irak mais
aussi sur le lien historique entre la
france et la russie entre la france et
la chine également on a toujours eu un
rôle particulier la france parce que on
est une nation internationale de par nos
territoires d'outre-mer de par notre
histoire aussi et donc
on a petit à petit perdu ça sur
l'alignement la nesque aujourd'hui si on
veut avoir un dialogue avec la russie
alors soit on a une voix différente soit
on est simplement un pion de plus dans
l'échiquier de l'otan qui servent les
intérêts des américains merci beaucoup
monsieur d'avoir été avec nous désole
pierre yves rougeron on vous entendra
pas ce soir sur sur la question manque
légèrement de temps mais on ne manquera
pas bien sûr devrait inviter deux
prochaines fois sur arte france pour
évoquer le sujet merci donc pierre-yves
rejoint d'avoir été avec nous président
du cercle de réflexion aristote et notre
éditorialiste merci à vous alexis
poulain